This is one of the biggest stories this week
and it is fascinating.
Donald Trump's former secretary of defense,
Jim Mattis, has completely denounced and condemned
Donald Trump.
And predictably, Donald Trump went completely
off the deep end, exploding in an unhinged
tirade last night.
It's truly something.
And I'm not aware of any time in history that
a secretary of defense has denounced the president.
They served so brutally and soul so completely
and so, so wholeheartedly.
I asked for other examples yesterday on Twitter
was not given any now.
I want to be clear.
I'm not any particular fan of Jim Mattis.
I'm not you know, I wasn't a big fan of Trump's
former secretary of state, Rex Tillerson.
But it can't be denied that they were two
of the calmer voices in Trump's administration
who were even remotely connected to reality.
Now, since leaving his position as secretary
of defense, Jim Mattis hasn't said very much
about Donald Trump.
And he even said, I think it was about a year
ago or so roughly, that he doesn't really
plan or think it's appropriate.
I'm summarizing here to criticize the sitting
president, the president they worked for.
Clearly, that has changed.
And Jim Mattis has now denounced Trump and
accused him of ordering the military to violate
the constitutional rights of Americans.
Understand that the former Trump's own former
secretary of defense is accusing Trump of
trying to violate the constitutional rights
of Americans.
Let's look at some of Madison's letter.
Then we will get Trump's explosive and completely
predictable reaction.
Mattis wrote, I have watched this week's unfolding
events angry and appalled.
The words equal justice under law are carved
in the pediment of the United States Supreme
Court.
This is precisely, precisely what protesters
are rightly demanding.
It is a wholesome and unifying demand, one
that all of us should be able to get behind.
We must not be distracted by a small number
of lawbreakers.
The protests are defined by tens of thousands
of people of conscience who are insisting
that we live up to our values, our values
as people and our values as a nation.
We must reject and hold accountable those
in office who would make a mockery of our
Constitution.
Then Jim Mattis goes on to say in this letter,
absolutely brutally that, quote, Donald Trump
is the first president in my lifetime who
does not try to unite the American people,
does not even pretend to try.
Instead, he tries to divide us.
We are witnessing the consequences of three
years of this deliberate effort.
years without mature leadership.
We can unite without him drawing on the strength
inherent in our civil society.
This will not be easy as the past few days
have shown.
But we owe it to our fellow citizens, to past
generations that bled to defend our promise
and to our children.
Then Mattis, who if nothing else, he chooses
his words carefully, actually references Nazis,
saying, quote, Instructions given by the military
departments to our troops before the Normandy
invasion reminded soldiers that the Nazi slogan
for destroying us was divide and conquer.
Our American answer is in union, there is
strength.
We must summon that unity to surmount this
crisis, confident that we are better than
our politics.
And then lastly, talking about the Constitution,
which like him or not, and I'm no big Mattis
fan, he genuinely does seem to care about
the Constitution, regardless of who it is
that is in power, saying, quote, When I joined
the military some 50 years ago, I swore an
oath to support and defend the Constitution.
Never did I dream that troops taking that
same oath would be ordered under any circumstance
to violate the constitutional rights of their
fellow citizens, much less to provide a bizarre
photo op for the elected commander in chief
with military leadership standing alongside,
referencing, of course, that horrifying photo
op earlier this week where Donald Trump gassed
protest.
Had protesters gassed.
He didn't do it himself to clear a path to
his Bible photo op in front of St. John's
Church.
I am not aware of such a brutal takedown of
a president by their own former secretary
of defense.
If you have an example, I am more than willing
to see it.
Now, Trump's reaction, you have to see Trump's
reaction when the Maddis letter was published
yesterday.
I was just waiting for Trump to go completely
crazy.
It took a couple of hours, but he eventually
did tweeting, quote, Probably the only thing
Barack Obama and I have in common is that
we both had the honor of firing Jim Mattis,
the world's most overrated general.
I asked for.
Letter of resignation and felt great about
it.
His nickname was Chaos, which I didn't like,
and change to Mad Dog.
His primary strength was not military, but
rather personal public public relations.
I gave him a new life, things to do and battles
to win.
But he seldom brought home the bacon.
I didn't like his leadership style or much
else about him, and many others agree.
Glad he is gone.
Now, what's really amazing about Trump's response
is that, you know, Trump's furious.
You can see his anger.
Trump is seething that his own former secretary
of defense brutally has condemned him, but
he can't really come up with much to criticize
Jim Mattis with.
He's an overrated general.
And Trump said that so many times.
It's a milquetoast insult.
I didn't like his nickname, so I changed it.
Who?
Who cares?
He was better at PR than military stuff.
That speaks more about Trump's poor judgment
of who to hire.
Right.
Trump ran on.
I will hire the best people.
How?
If this is true.
If Matt Maddis is better at PR than military
stuff.
How did Trump stupidly hire him to run the
secretary of Defense?
You don't have to like Mattis.
I am no Big Jim Mattis fan.
But if you say whose values do I prefer guiding
the country?
Trump's, which are mi, mi, mi or Matisses,
which at least are ostensibly the Constitution
and an appropriate interpretation of it.
I pick Mattis over Trump every time.
Now, one more thing.
Mattis seems to have the goods on Trump by
all estimates.
If Jet Jim Mattis wanted to, he could actually
reveal things about Trump that may be worse
than anything we've seen yesterday when the
Mattis letter came out.
New York Times magazine's Robert Draper tweeted,
quote, Mattis is still holding back, though
he's privately told friends that Trump's behavior
is far worse than the reports and that the
republic is on shaky footing.
He knows so much more than he's currently
divulging.
The reporting is a horror, a horror story.
So if the truth is worse than the reporting,
as Jim Mattis reportedly said.
Imagine what we don't know.
Imagine what we might know in four weeks as
Donald Trump continues to unravel.
Part of that unraveling appears to be Trump's
campaign.
Looking at the 2020 map and panicking.
And that's what I want to talk
about next.